This video is made possible by brilliant,
so you're going to learn more about brilliant later in today's video bus.
If you'd like to learn more about them.
Right now,
I've got a brilliant.org forward slash or biographics.
They'll also find a link in the description below.
Leonardo da Vinci was a genius who invented revolutionary ideas centuries before
the rest of the world would catch up with him.
He embodies the definition of a renaissance man,
one who studied and mastered a variety of different subjects.
He was a painter,
an engineer,
or an architect or right,
or a scientist and an invents up.
While you may know him for his most famous works like the Mona Lisa or the last
supper,
few people know the man behind the paintings.
Today on biographics,
we're telling you all about the anodic Da Vinci.
My baby boy named Leonardo was born on April the 15 1452 and a Tuscan village
called Vinci.
The child was born out of wedlock to a wealthy legal notary named mess-up,
yarrow,
Fru Senio to Antonio and to beautiful peasant girl named Catarina Dimio lippy.
His father took responsibility for the boy and raised him on the family,
a stage with his wife,
but as a bastard child,
a young Leonardo was not even allowed to be given his father's last name.
He was simply called the NR Two da Vinci,
which means Leonardo Da Vinci lived with his biological mother and son.
He was five years old when his father took over the responsibility of raising
him.
Casuarina went on to marry a man who was simply referred to as the fight up.
Leonardo's father Massa and married a 16 year old Nobel girl named Al Barrier
Ends.
They have legitimate children of their own.
Instead of going to school,
the country signed was young Leonardo's classroom.
Even as a young age,
he was inquisitive and he truly fell in love with nature.
He wished that men could fly like the birds and swim through the oceans like the
fish.
Together with his brothers,
they played games of war and he imagines being triumphant in battle like the men
and the stories that were told by his father.
However,
this stage of innocence,
it couldn't last forever.
As he grew up in the NRD learns that he would not be allowed to inherit the
family estate.
[inaudible] had nine brothers and three sisters,
so even if he could inherit his father's estate,
it's not like there's going to be much to go around.
It's like,
well,
the Anado hands,
I learn a trade and figure out how to take care of himself.
Now in medieval florins guilds,
they were sort of like today's trade unions and they were split up into multiple
categories of jobs that a man could choose from.
So long as he was born into the right social class,
the highest ranking guilds were called the RTM.
Maggiore and his father would have been a part of the guild for powerful
lawyers,
judges,
and notaries,
but as an illegitimate child,
this was like being in the lower class and he was not even allowed to join the
[inaudible] guild categories,
which middle class workers like blacksmiths stonemasons were a part of.
His only option was to join the guild,
which held lower cost jobs like beggars and Miller's.
However,
they're nodoz father.
He still wanted his son to have a good life.
Now he could see that the boy had a natural talent for art.
So his father introduced him to a man called Andre at Dell very Archie own.
He ran an old studio in the city of Florence off to seeing the boys sketches.
He agreed to take him on as an apprentice.
Okay.
Andre Delver Akio had several artists and craftsmen working for him in his
workshop.
He would take on commissions from the wealthy and the powerful and the DC family
and divide the work amongst his students and employees.
Their studio works on improving the beauty of the city.
They had to work with all mediums,
whether it was carving marble statues,
Costing Matt a law,
painting portraits,
even architecture,
bridges and lots of other civil engineering projects were all sketched by
members of their skilled.
So this made it necessary for Leonardo to learn multiple disciplines.
After a few years of training,
Leonardo Da Vinci assisted Verrocchio and painting a commissions piece for the
Catholic Church gold,
the baptism of Christ.
This was a very large mural on the wall of a church,
so there was plenty of space for two artists to stands and work on the painting
at the same time.
Rocky Akio instructed Leonardo depends.
Two angels that had been included in his rough sketch when Da Vinci was done,
Rockiyo was in total shock.
He could not believe how gorgeous and lifeline because the painting was.
He knew that the students had already surpassed the master.
By his mid Twenties Leonardo Da Vinci became a master artist at [inaudible]
studio and Deon himself a reputation.
Then I'll do conducted a lot of experiments with arts like studying how like
change the shading on an object or the perfect time of data sketch someone's
face.
However his talents,
it was also a curse because it caused a lot of jealousy among the art community.
At 24 years old,
Da Vinci was accused of having sex with a male prostitute and he was arrested
for sodomy.
At that time,
the punishment for Saul to me was being burned to death,
but when he went to trial,
no evidence was presented and no witnesses came forward and they simply could
not prove that had done anything illegal,
so they had to let him go.
However,
even though he was found not guilty,
still wrote in his journals that this scandal very seriously hurt.
His reputation for Yukon's wanted to work with them in forums despite his
obvious talent.
Now we don't know Da Vinci's actual sexual orientation.
We only know that he never got married.
Some believe that he chose to be celebrated in order to focus on his work.
At the end of the day,
whoever turned him into the authorities definitely wanted him dead.
As awful as this sounds,
medieval times,
they were truly cut throat and none of high standing always had to watch their
backs to make sure they were not killed by their enemies and assassin named
Bernardo demand.
Dino Baron and Jelly stabby on her demo DG in the streets simply because they
were both from rival banking families.
One of Leonardo's earliest known sketches was his observation of Marin Shelley's
body and the,
and it was titled the hanged man.
Often with this dispute between the Baron cellies and the [inaudible] families
Florence in Naples,
they were on the brink of war,
the men in Da Vinci's gills.
They were forced to stop working on art and to use their engineering skills to
defend the city.
Since da Vinci was a bastard,
he could not become a knight and serve in the role court.
Instead,
he started to design ladders and massive weapons to help defend the Florence
should they ever need it.
Perhaps he saw this as his way to be remembered in the history books.
During the three month time period,
the city was on edge believing they were on the brink of war.
When Lorenzo muddy tree roots islands off often making a successful peace
treaty.
The rest of the city celebrated but Leonardo,
he was actually disappointed.
After peace returned to the city,
the artist's skills could go back to making beautiful things,
but this was no longer challenging or interesting to Vinci.
When he was 29 years old,
he was asked to do his first commissioned the mural as a church all by himself.
The painting was called adoration of the Magi Ans he took his concept above and
beyond what any other painter had done previously.
It was an incredible piece,
But da Vinci didn't seem to see that because it's off to spending a very long
time working on the piece.
He decided that he simply could not finish the painting.
He was very restless at that time and he didn't have the patience to actually
sit and complete a lot of his projects.
He had so many brilliant ideas,
but he sometimes had trouble executing on them.
Da Vinci was actually sued more than one,
so getting paid by a patron that then failing to finish the work as he promised.
This couples with the accusation of sodomy meant that his talents who is simply
not enough to make up for his bad reputation.
You thought that now maybe it was the time to start over some way.
New.
Now just before we get into Da Vinci's new stage of life,
I do want to quickly tell you about brilliance.
Now I can't promise you that they'll turn you into the next Da Vinci,
but I can promise you that brilliant will improve your understanding of what he
and the other great scientists have done.
Brilliant science learning platform that allow you to learn through something
called active learning,
which sums up is basically the opposite of that feeling of reading a really
complex paragraph about some principal and then having no idea what on earth
they're talking about.
Even if you've read it a dozen times and it's not just the basics.
That brilliant cover though,
they totally covered the basics as well.
They go all the way through to things like complex statistics and a whole lot
house.
Whether you want to like Da Vinci,
look at some classical mechanics or maybe you want to jump ahead just a few
years and look at special relativity or quantum objects.
Brilliant.
Makes even the most complex concepts,
easy to understand.
They give you something super short to read.
It's just a few lines.
It's very easy to get through and then you immediately apply what you just
learned to a problem.
You simply rinse and repeat that and suddenly,
or understanding a whole bunch of stuff that you didn't think you would be.
I've been using brilliant and I think you should go try it out just to see how
fascinated is for such a complex subject to be so easily grasped.
You can support biographics beginnings,
a brilliant.org forward slash biographics unless get back to Da Vinci.
Even though he was more talented than many of the other painters in Florence,
Leonardo da Vinci still went through a midlife crisis when he was 30 years old.
He realized that the lifestyle of a professional artist,
it did not suit him and he craved the adventure of having a career in web and
design.
He had an entire book filled with incredible inventions that would not be made
until years later.
This included things like a tanker,
giant crossbow,
underwater scuba gear,
and even a robotic soldier.
He was truly a hundreds of years ahead of his time,
but without a war of these weapons,
they never actually came to life.
Leonardo Da Vinci,
you plan to move to Milan,
the most northern Italian status.
He also wanted to secure employment before he made that Johnny.
So we know why he wants us to leave Florence,
but why did he choose Milan?
Well,
that's because the city was much closer to France,
so there were far more interested in gathering weapons to defend the country.
Da Vinci sends a lesser to the Duke of Milan,
claiming that he was a weapon design expert.
And the included a few pages from his sketch book.
At the very ends of the letter,
he also included a single line mentioning that he was also a painter.
This [inaudible] Vico sportster,
the temporary Duke of Milan.
He was holding this position of power in Zilla.
His nephew came of age.
This faults family had not been in power for very long,
especially compared to the likes of the muddy cheese.
So volt's a invited Leonardo Da Vinci to visit and he was overjoyed,
hoping that he would finally be able to make that career change that he wanted.
But once he got there,
he was gravely disappointed to find out that the Duke wanted him to paint a
portrait of his beautiful mistress today,
that Boucher discord lady with an Amen.
Even though he came to Milan to escape being a painter,
he's still blew people away with his talents.
So also was so impressed that he commissioned a statue of a 24 foot tall horse.
Da Vinci told him that it would take at least three years to complete.
In reality,
though,
Da Vinci was stalling for time because without the help of his old master
studio,
he had no idea how it was going to pull off a 20 foot tall metal cost horse.
There's divorces.
They were establishing themselves and the Duke of Milan believed that paying for
things like metal statues would somehow prove that permanence in high society.
At first,
Da Vinci created the horse out of clay and it was unveiled at a party.
It's impressed them so much that Da Vinci was accepted into this falls or royal
court.
Unfortunately,
like a lot of his projects,
Da Vinci,
while I was in a bit over his head and he was running out of time by a stroke of
luck sports or decided to go to war and they needed the metal resources for his
armies weapons.
Once again,
Leonardo Da Vinci fault that this,
this might be the time that he can shine with his weapons buff that were not
enough resources to pay for that creation.
The Duke of Milan gave him her new assignment in decorating a church called
Santa Maria del Grad Ceo,
which is where he painted one of his most famous works.
The last suffered at the time.
The priests were actually very annoyed with him because it took him over three
years to the painting for the next 17 years,
Da Vinci,
android,
a life of financial security and respect and his forces royal court.
During the time that he lived in Milan da Vinci at a secret projects this,
he never dared to tell anyone.
He was dissecting human cadavers and sketching their bodies,
muscles and organs.
He also made a wax costs of the organs.
Now this all sounds rather creepy and Da Vinci knew this,
which is why he kept this sketchbook a secrets,
and it only showed up in the 16 hundreds at that time,
autopsies and any other form of disturbing the dead was frowned upon by the
Catholic Church.
You already knew what it was like to have a solid reputation back in Florence,
so he was far more careful this time,
essentially leading a double life,
even though his sketchbook was found over a hundred years later,
his studies of the human body,
they were revolutionary and became the foundation of modern anatomy.
Then I'll do da Vinci would Ronnie's in notebooks about his scientific
experiments,
his inventions and autistic ideas that are of a 15,000 pages.
It was notes that have survived.
Even wrote some of those notes backwards so you could,
and you read them when looking in a mirror.
Some people believe that he did this because he was worried that people would
steal his ideas.
When Leonardo Da Vinci was 50 years old,
this falls or family lost their position of power and the French invaded Milan.
When they saw the giants play horse statue of standing on the stage.
They used it for Tanya practice.
Then I'll do da Vinci.
He had to leave Milan with the bare necessities including his journals,
but he left all of his works of art behind.
He decided to travel from place to place once again,
trying to pitch us ideas for military weaponry around Italy.
He showed the Duke of Venice is ideas which included a snorkeling suit for
breathing underwater that actually worked.
He had ideas on how humans could fly or walk on the bottom of the ocean given
mind.
This was at a time when people didn't even have clocks or watches to tell time.
While all of his ideas were amazing,
they were far too ahead of his time and the Duke of Venice didn't find any need
for these inventions.
Da Vinci.
He was forced to reluctantly move back to Florence.
He was reluctant because if they're that everyone would still remember his bad
reputation,
but it was actually far worse than that.
By that time,
the people had forgotten all about the name Leonardo Da Vinci and there was a
new genius in town,
Michelangelo,
and he was just 26 years old.
Since the art world in Florence was so competitive,
Leonardo hated Michelangelo almost immediately.
Da Vinci was clearly jealous and had to find reasons to dislike Michelangelo.
He would rights angrily in his journal about how he thought the young man was
dirty and undignified.
This is why the long there do you see in most depictions of Da Vinci actually
spent all of his younger years making sure that he was always clean shaven and
you're always wore the finest of clothes.
He even had professional musicians playing music for his clients while they sat
for their portraits and the whole process.
It was sort of like going to a luxury spa.
Michelangelo on the other hands,
he had the polar opposite approach to his art.
He was so focused on his work that he would forget to shave for days and that
his beard grow out.
You less chips of stone and dust cover his home after working on a statue and it
was far more like a workshop than a comfortable place for clients to stay.
The two artists,
they deeply disliked each other and even once got into a fight in public
secretly Da Vinci would go home to write about how depressed he was to be
getting older as well as writing about the fear and anxiety that ruled his
thoughts.
Since da Vinci could no longer secure his place in the foreign science scene,
he decided to try his luck at weapon design.
One last time,
Pope Alexander had a bastard son named Cesari board job.
Some people say that he was aggrieved leader while others see the Bordeaux was a
bloodthirsty really who kills his,
anyone.
He got in his way,
Machiavelli his famous book called the prince was even based on border as an
example of what a ruler must do in order to stay in power.
Da Vinci centers,
sketches to border and finally here and someone saying yes to his weapons.
He became chief general engineer for board and supervise the construction of
towers,
weapons and Birdseye view maps of the cities which she plans on invading,
which was revolutionary for the time.
Da Vinci got everything that he wanted,
but it was at a price he never expected.
The only reason why Borgia was willing to pay for the creation of all these
weapons was because he wanted to kill as many enemies as possible until this
point.
The idea of war and Sydney being just a concept to Leonardo Da Vinci and stories
of nights going into battle.
It seemed like fun.
For the first time in his life,
Da Vinci actually witnessed what a blood festy battle looked like and it was too
gruesome for him to handle.
He wrote,
truly man is more savage than beast for our brutality exceeds theirs.
We live by the death of others.
The straw that broke the camel's back was when Borgia ordered the death of one
of Da Vinci's close friends.
He quietly left border in the dead of the night and moved back to Florence where
he returns to a peaceful life painting portraits.
After selling those weapons,
Leonardo Da Vinci had saved a nice nest egg for his retirement and it was during
this time that he painted the Mona Lisa.
No one knows for sure who she actually is.
There are several theories,
but none have been confirmed.
Unlike all those portraits that were commissions and given away,
he carried the portrait of Mona Lisa with him for the rest of his life.
For once,
this was a piece of art that was done just for him,
but he was constantly changing it because he never felt he got it exactly right.
During his retirement,
he started to build massive wings for human buildings in the hopes that one day
people would fly.
He said,
there will be wings for man.
If it is not accomplished by me,
it will be accomplished someday by some other.
There is a commonly told story that during a flight attempt with these wings,
someone fell and broke their leg after this failed attempt.
He designed a motor that would flap the wings,
but it never worked properly.
However,
he did eventually designed the first wing that looks very much like what we use
in modern day airplanes besides the patrons that he served,
Leonardo Da Vinci was not.
He had a famous around the world.
He intended to publish books,
but he never actually went through with us.
As we mentioned Dahlia,
he wrote and sketched over 15,000 pages on a variety of subjects,
but he was a perfectionist,
so he continued to add more and more information because he never felt that his
work was complete.
Among these notes are multiple sketches of an old man with a beard.
Maybe we'll assume that this was his self portrait,
but no one knows for sure.
However,
this image is used to portray him in popular culture and it's how he is
remembered today.
Now,
King Frances,
the first of France had been collecting Da Vinci's pieces for years since he
wrote a letter to Da Vinci inviting him to live in his Chateau de Vinci.
He agreed to move to France when he was 65 years old.
He had a stroke,
which paralyzed is on the king's castle,
became his comfortable retirement place,
and he was given the very best medical cath and money could buy.
When he died in the year 1519 he left the Mona Lisa rent all of his sketch books
and journals to his law and apprentice born a bastard,
Leonardo da Vinci,
died like a king.
His life lives on forever and as well,
I continue.
We'll continue to serve as an inspiration to people around the world for
centuries to come.
So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos several times a week,
so hit that subscribe button and you will be notified when those come out.
And just always thank you for watching.